- Is it true that you and your brother
were named after "Lord
of the Rings" characters?
- Wow, you're really, really
digging me into a hole here.
Yes.
Yes, it's true.
Well, my brother is called Círdan
and if those "Lord of the
Rings" fans that are out there,
they might, they might recognize it.
He was, I believe, the elf
that took all the elves
from middle earth to wherever the elves go
at the end of the book.
He was the ship right and
that's, that's his character.
And my name, obviously, my
nickname was Sam, Samwise.
I wasn't christened that, but yes,
- It's a classic book.
- my parents were
probably hippies.
- It's a great, classic book.
- It is.
- And having hippies for
parents had to be fun,
let's be real.